the nfl under fire the league has
reportedly found no other current team
or league personnel to have sent emails
containing racist homophobic or
misogynistic language other than an
exchange of emails between former
raiders head coach john gruden and then
washington team president
bruce allen
las vegas raiders coach john gruden did
quit this week over a series of
offensive emails they were uncovered
during the league's investigation of
alleged misconduct by officials of the
washington football team the nfl has
refused to release a final report on
that investigation critics say the
league is hiding other evidence of bias
and bad behavior
emily applegate says she continues to
live with the trauma she suffered while
working as a marketing coordinator with
the washington football team a half
decade ago it's like day three and my
immediate boss who is the cmo was
already saying things to me about the
way i looked my appearance and then it
just snowballed he would take pictures
of me on his phone which i didn't know
all the time applegate was one of the
first women to speak out about
washington's workplace culture an
ensuing league investigation concluded
the team had a toxic culture rife with
sexual harassment but after more than a
hundred interviews and six hundred fifty
thousand emails obtained no formal
written report was released the only
major punishment a 10 million dollar
fine for team owner daniel snyder it's
completely revictimizing it's telling us
that everything that we went through
every personal detail that we shared
was not important enough to make any
kind of change but applegate hasn't
given up this week she and nine other
former washington employees turned to
the nfl's biggest sponsors calling on
them to pressure the league to release
the findings of the investigation to the
public when you have a sponsor paying
you millions of dollars and they're
telling you you know what we want to see
this too that's going to do the most
damage in the letter to sponsors the
group wrote the consequence of mr
goodell's decisions around the
investigation and the lack of any
meaningful action against dan snyder is
to tell women and survivors everywhere
you and your experiences do not matter
to the nfl it is the first instance i
can recall in which there was not a
written report amy trask was the first
female ceo in the league and is now an
nfl analyst for cbs sports going to
sponsors and trying to apply pressure
is that a
smart way to try to incentivize the nfl
or force the nfl's hand it's a tried and
true
method so i'm not surprised that they're
doing it but i don't know if it will
work for applegate the fight extends
beyond the nfl this isn't just a sports
issue this is an issue throughout any
industry in order for us to make a great
change why not
start with one of the most recognized
organizations in the world
we reached out to the six major nfl
sponsors mentioned in that letter who
was sent that letter but have not heard
back the group applegate is working with
may not be alone in their fight though
the nfl players association has said it
plans to petition the nfl and call for
the release of all the emails associated
with the investigation and amy trask and
i discussed this idea of transparency
and why not say
this is who we were
we're working on getting better show
everybody what's there obviously there
are a lot of issues and there are other
things we may or may not know but all we
can do is speculate unless a formal
written report is released is there any
indica was there any question all the
emails come out the nfl so far has said
that they are not releasing any of this
information but the nfl players
association once they start negotiating
their collective bargaining agreement
could have some sway if they do try to
hold out to get these emails released
and see what else is in there it is
larger
than just the nfl we've seen this over
and over again when bad behavior is
investigated sometimes the results of
those investigations are not made public
they need to be
transparency